Okay, let's take a quiz.
In this scenario we have some large software under test,
and part of it is a library that's been flaky and has been giving us problems.
Let's say this library is implementing numerical functions,
and these numerical functions have been sometimes throwing floating point exceptions
and crashing our system.
What happens is the vendor has given us a new version,
but what we don't want to do is just roll that directly into our production system
because in the past we've gotten burned by that sort of thing
where we have deployed a new version and it contains flaws
that were worse than the flaws in the previous version.
What we're going to do is we're going to spend some time checking this thing out
and trying to make sure that even if it's not that great
it's at least not worse than the previous version.
The question I have for you is what kind of testing is this most like?
Is it unit testing?
Is it white box testing? Is it black box testing?
Or, on the other hand, is it stress testing?
Okay, please take a minute to mark what you think is the best answer.